did you ever have anyone telling you  that your work is not messy mesi is one  of these terms used so frequently in  consulting that it's almost a cliche but  what exactly does mesi stand for missy  stands for mutually exclusive  collectively exhaustive it is a rule of  thumb that should be applied whenever  you want to break something down into  smaller parts for instance you might  want to create a document about a topic  and then to break down the topic into  smaller parts for the table of content  mutually exclusive means that the  different parts of your table of  contents should not overlap so you  should discuss the same element only in  one section collectively exhaustive  means that all the parts together should  form the overarching topic again so if  your elements are not overlapping and  complete you likely came up with a good  structure this structure is measy follow  for more insights